♪
♪.
ABBY: WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW" LAUNCHING A
CRIMINAL PROBE INTO THE
AFTERWORLD CHAOS THAT LEFT EIGHT
PEOPLE DEAD AND HOSPITALIZED
DOZENS MORE POLICE CONFIRMED
BEING PORTS IN SOME OF THE
VICTIMS MAY HAVE BEEN INJECTED
WITH DRUGS BY A NEEDLE WITH THE
SECURITY GUARD AMONG THOSE
POSSIBLY PREDICT.
>> THE SECURITY OFFICER WAS
REACHING OVER TO RESTRAIN OR
GRAB A CITIZEN AND HE FELT A
PRICK IN HIS NECK AND THE
MEDICAL STAFF NOTICED THE PRICK
THAT WAS SIMILAR TO A PRICK THAT
YOU WOULD GET 70s TRYING TO
INJECT.
ABBY: TRAVIS SCOTT SAYS HE'S
DEVASTATED ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
WHILE HE WAS PERFORMING.
>> I'M HONESTLY JUST DEVASTATED,
I COULD NEVER IMAGINE ANYTHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENING.
I'M CLOSE TO EVERYONE TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
ALICIA: IT'S WORTH NOTING THIS
ISN'T THE FIRST TIME HE'S BEEN
IN TROUBLE WITH THE LAW.
ON TWO SEPARATE OCCASIONS IN
2015 AND 2018, SCOTT PLEADED
GUILTY TO MISDEMEANOR CHARGES OF
RECKLESS CONDUCT AFTER TELLING
FANS TO JUMP BARRICADES, RUSH
THE STAGE AND BYPASS SECURITY
DURING CONCERT IN CHICAGO AND
ARKANSAS.
ABBY I WANT TO CONTINUE FIRST,
WHAT ORIGINATED AS A RUMOR BUT
THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE ARE FEELING
SYRINGE JOBS COMING OUT OF
NOWHERE.
ABBY: OUR HEARTS AND PRAYERS GO
OUT TO THE FAMILY OF EVERYONE
WHO DIED.
TO THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
KONTHER IS AN INNOCENT THING,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE FUN,
SOMEWHAT POTENTIALLY PRICKING
OTHER PEOPLE IN THE NECK AND
INJECTING WITH DRUGS.
I AM SPEECHLESS THINKING ABOUT
IT.
ACTUALLY SOME OF THE NAMES OF
THE VICTIMS WERE RELEASED AND
THEIR PHOTOS, JOHN 14-YEAR-OLD
RIATA, 16, FRANK, 21, RUDY 23
AND WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT TRAVIS
SCOTT AND THE FACT THAT HE
ENCOURAGES BEHAVIOR BEFORE IT IS
ACTUALLY BEEN SUED AND ARRESTED
FOR AND HAS NOT LEARNED HIS
LESSON.
I HOPE OTHER ARTISTS ARE SEEING
THIS IN THEIR ENCOURAGED TO
ENCOURAGE THIS BEHAVIOR AFTER
CONCERT AS WELL.
ALICIA: WE ARE JUST LEARNING
THAT THE FIRST LAWSUIT IN THIS
CASE HAS BEEN FILED ON BEHALF OF
OF ONE OF THE VICTIMS THAT SEEKS
$1 MILLION, IT'S AGAINST TRAVIS
SCOTT LIVE NATION, THE ORGANIZER
AND DRAKE THE PERFORMER WHO WAS
ALSO ON STAGE WITH TRAVIS SCOTT.
THIS IS JUST GOING TO BE THE
BEGINNING.
CHARLIE: WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
LAST NIGHT, ALL WE COULD SAY IS
MY GOODNESS HOW TERRIBLE AND
TRAGIC OUR HEARTS WENT OUT TO
THE FAMILIES.
AS NEW INFORMATION COMES OUT,
YOU START TO WONDER WHAT THE
HELL IS GOING ON IN THIS PLACE
YOU ALWAYS WANT TO TRY TO FIND A
REASON, SOME EXPLANATION FOR WHY
SOMETHING HAPPENED ESPECIALLY IF
IT'S SENSELESS.
IT'S A HUMAN NATURE TO GRASP FOR
EXPLANATIONS.
SOMETHING LIKE THIS YOU HAVE TO
DEFINE EXPLANATIONS.
BUT IF IN FACT THIS GUY, TRAVIS
SCOTT WHO WAS A RECORD TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE HIS FANS TO RUSH THE
STAGE, IF IN FACT ALL THE
VIDEOTAPE WOULD'VE GONE THROUGH
IN THE FOOTAGE OF PEOPLE
INSTAGRAM MAIN AND DOING STUFF
OFF THEIR PHONES IS ALL GOING TO
BE LOOKED THROUGH.
IF IN FACT HE DID THAT AGAIN, HE
SHOULD BE LOCKED UP AND SHOULD
BE SUED FOR MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
HE SHOULD BE SUED OUT OF
EXISTENCE.
THIS CONCEPT THAT THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE THINGS THAT
YOU DO AND THE THINGS THAT YOU
SAY ESPECIALLY IN A CROWDED
BOISTEROUS ENVIRONMENT LIKE
THIS, IT IS SHOCKING BEYOND
WORDS.
ALICIA: WERE JUST LOADING UP THE
LAWSUIT, THE INVESTIGATION IS
UNDERWAY WHO DON'T KNOW WHO WILL
BE HELD LIABLE.
IN THE LAWSUIT THEY CALLED THIS
PREDICTABLE.
THIS WAS PREDICTABLE AND THE
FACT THAT THIS IS HAPPENED IN
THE PAST, I JUST WONDER.
EVEN IF TRAVIS GOT DINNER
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE IN THIS MOMENT
TO RUSH THE STAGE, IF HIS FANS
KNOW THAT HE'S DONE THAT IN THE
PAST, I'M WONDERING IF THAT
COULD COME INTO PLAY.
>> IT'S A GREAT, GREAT QUESTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT ANY SITUATION YOU
NEED LOOK AT A GUY CALL PAUL
RIEMER HE LED AN INVESTIGATION
OF A 1979 CONCERT CRASH THAT
KILLED 11 PEOPLE IN CINCINNATI.
HE SAYS THE HOUSTON AUTHORITIES
DID NOT DO ENOUGH TO KEEP THE
CROWD SAFE.
THE CROWD IN HOUSTON NEVER
SHOULD'VE GOTTEN THAT BIG
INDENTS, IS A PREVENTABLE
TRAGEDY THAT HAPPENED BECAUSE
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS WERE IGNORED
AND BECAUSE THERE ARE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS HERE TO BE MADE.
THAT ABOUT WRAPS IT UP.
ALICIA: I THINK THIS COULD BE A
QUESTION THAT WILL HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED, HOW DO YOU HANDLE
CROWD SIZE AT THESE FESTIVALS.
50000 PEOPLE IN ATTENDANCE OF
THE FESTIVAL WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
GENERAL ADMISSION.
YOU KIND OF ASSUME ONE PERSON
GOES, A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE GET
A GO AS WELL.
ABBY: I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY IT,
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN CONTROL
A CROWD OF THAT SIZE.
I THINK IT WOULD HAVE TO COME
FROM THE ORGANIZERS NOT SELLING
AS MANY TICKETS.
THAT MONEY IS WORTH IT TO SPARE
SOMEONE'S LIFE.
I LISTEN TO SOMEONE ELSE TALK
ABOUT THIS ALSO THEY SAID MAYBE
HAD ASSIGNED SEAT AND NOT A MOSH
PIT.
I THINK THERE WAS A LOT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM WHAT I READ, I
SAID THIS YESTERDAY BUT THE
HOUSTON MAYOR SAID THERE WAS
MORE SECURITY AT THIS EVENT TO
THE WORLD SERIES, THEIR 50000
PLUS PEOPLE.
I THINK YOU HIT ON THE HEADS I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU C